for me it's not about money I got money
I got I got plenty of money I never
thought I'd be a pro boxer five years
ago as long as one's where I be looking
for and you know I fight a journeyman I
fight Jake or whoever and then I keep
going and all of a sudden there might be
an opportunity where I do fight someone
for what I mean so were in a camp we
were surrounded by the top guys in the
sport that's gonna make a difference
making sure when I come into this next
fight I'm just levels above anything
anyone ever thought I'm a [__]
machine you can't [__] move me I'd
say with the loss I was tentative I was
you know I was just avoiding [__] now
I'm not afraid to get here now I'll stay
you in the face and do that you punch me
in that did [__] oh now I'm going to
punish you for that Logan's gonna see
that I'm just going to scatter shove if
Logan was ever gonna be JJ would have
been in that first bag watching him pie
is the worst like the wellif I I thought
he was losing I'm training like a killer
you're not ready for this I'm literally
a completely different boxing
we assume that he's gonna come out quite
strong so he's gonna go ham for maybe
round 1 round 2 if that doesn't work
then he's [__]
this week on the true jory podcast que
si Vidal Reilly
Simon min as well hello preciate lads
the first time we ever did a podcast
together I was in some little [__]
not far from here he was telling the
stories were like oh yeah if someone
starts in the nightclub I just got my
bodyguard on of them and now I'm like
he's about to go and fight this [__]
big bust at a little pole and punch his
face and have your way and it's like
you're a different person
yeah I mean I've changed a lot in the
past few years man
it's [__] man right see III enjoy it
like basi trainings just like it's given
me like in new new life new men like
mentally it's just freshen me up I feel
how you know since day one
how different are we saying here's a
woman I mean I known him since yes Evan
where he was a little kind of fat nerd
when you know this is this was like five
years before that Wow yeah yeah he's
changed
something about I think a lot like a lot
about old school friends wouldn't even
believe like I'll be able to do this nah
they'll look at me and be like this is
ridiculous like how I'm now firing on a
pro card even I think that me and I look
and when I met you I was like this what
you've done is ridiculous but even I'm
like I never experienced this is what
have you done with our what have you
created monsters that's what I do you're
getting on the plane tomorrow
yeah do you feel like cuz you've been
saying to me this is when the real work
starts this is what is true because now
again the experts in so you know me and
Leon have built a machine you can say to
a certain point and now we're taking it
to the experts to take it turn next to
me well yeah and Stitch you know even
the little things how you wrap your
hands you know warming up and the
strength and conditioning you know that
the exercises that are specific to world
champions you know they use the same
system so it's exciting it's very
exciting yeah you know you were even
realize how lucky is
yeah but I've been buzzing different as
all like you haven't even been boxing
that long so when you realize after what
two fights you've got world championship
coaches yeah moving our far three like
who's Jeff weirdly Jeff coached yeah the
big man we haven't break this is such a
weird thing with Logan
[Music]
so I'm Jeff train Shannon breaks to win
his first world title yeah and then
after that fight Shannon left Jeff so
Jeff trained Shannon's first defense
opponent and took the belt back off
Shannon and it's like it's like and
could he do it again
this would be like even worse revenge
cuz now Shannon spilled the yeast off
into a whole new identity as a as a
coach yeah cuz he's not really known as
a fighter he's known as a personality
yeah you know no one googles him for
fights it's just like trolling pitch go
that's his mean came to famous
personality is what yeah made him but
this is the thing when you watch his
fights he was a bad man
to be fair girls would be use dangerous
and Larry three first-round knockout 77
37 is Ricky Bobby is wrong one thing I
did say those this was a guy who for he
went after him in the first round and he
weathered the storm and then the guy
just got in the third round just
finished him off a new year he he was
brutal in that first round but if you
could get past it and you know exactly
everything settles down then you really
see who's more skillful at the beginning
is just that athleticism yeah who's more
powerful who's explosive after that it's
actually who learned something that's
gonna get you from if you feel like
that's a bit of a tell for the log and
see what I see the other day I walked up
to him in
all right me he didn't look like the
same login from a year ago he was vegan
and like my name he looked like my size
but without the fat I was like [__] dude
you look huge and in my head like I've
got a lot of respect for you fighting
the kid who's that much bigger than you
he's naturally a [__] yeah yeah yeah
like he's [__] huge so I'm by Perl is
no point
mmm that's why it's a sport in a myth is
pretty this way that the heavyweight
division wouldn't exist if you know a
few kilos made it if what Artie Ruiz was
living proof that David he was value
even they were hacked for stoner Park
what so of course he's a bigger person
might I've seen loads of big people get
knocked up my press conference was was
intense it idea we felt Logan he brought
his best yet because it was so [__] in
the last London press conference for me
was i I've got a [__] turn up this
time yeah I mean he couldn't do any
worse yeah you busy did stand-up comedy
like Dave Chappelle
but there's a little bit of a video of
you sort of rolling your shoulders and
sort of frowning at one point and people
are sort of reading into that I've I
he's not as confident this time oh yeah
and yet Khan
our cameraman message mean he was I I've
never seen JJ more confidence yeah he's
like this is the Joella confidence well
I mean with that little clip I literally
couldn't hear what he was saying like me
I would let you just like yeah was he
sounds just yelling hoping people saw
one thing that yeah on the sky
broadcast they turned the crowd down the
heroes you couldn't yeah yeah yeah you
answering questions I'm like I hope I
was good yeah so how's training going so
far yeah good like I feel good I feel
ready ready go Vegas and just pretty
much the icing icing on the cake right
now going to Vegas literally just
topping up everything we know and yeah
yeah just going going to town like I'm
ready for how Logan's going to fight and
even if he switches that are polite I'm
ready like
whereas before his job was a huge
problem I've cancer that now like I know
I'm gonna be able to just get past that
and then if you want to defer something
else I'll be able to get past that as
well so for you yo but you must you've
got a game plan yeah yeah we have a game
of course yeah we have a game out of
what we're going to do
yes have more than one game yeah it's
nicely that's the game plan is have more
than one game per because boxing changes
and anytime so we can't go in there now
I'm gonna do this it's now okay yeah
we're first what you're gonna do just
look at me and win you know you have to
have more things so that's what their
camps about one of my memories was when
you went on tour I was I [__] a lot of
Pizza my permission I'm just saying nas
is me like you know this guy's going
into a fight in your life this guy's
going on to us probably not the best
[__] thing before you fight yeah he
was coming home and like working out
still constantly I think that's part of
it is actually because you've been so
private and then you only see you on
tour no everyone just assumes out well
he must be doing anything well I mean
they've seen footage of me just being
fat and just like being a meme etc like
I haven't shown much footage and I think
that's a lot that's how people basing
everything on yeah I think right now
logan's the favorite betting why to you
it's part of that is the size of the
guys size and what he's shown like it
I've just hardly shown anything like and
I can guarantee like I'm completely
different to how I fought Logan in the
first fight yeah but obviously I don't
want to show as much as I did last time
because I felt like that was my downfall
I showed him too much and that's why I
was able to do so well in the first few
rounds now anyone on toys his physical
condition went down but that doesn't
mean that he's not he's a Q and oh yeah
you know you still have as much time to
learn it's just that why do I physically
need to be in shape to fight if I don't
know him fighting I'm gonna do something
else but he's still gonna learn the game
in the background so now I was just
getting the physical side and my hero
start yeah were you in a relationship
last fight uh yeah
are you single now no I'm still relays
really
I just wondered if that would have
affected anything right now Logan was
saying when he was on he was I yeah I'm
single it's much better being sick it's
just hard out here give your time door
because your time management is gonna be
[__] hardcore when you're in oh if
anything I think it's better being a
relationship because I don't go out as
much yeah I feel like before like every
time I I'd always want to go out to try
and get girls cuz you know be single
blah blah blah it's now I'm like there's
no point like I've already got a
girlfriend this car she's not coming to
you with Ella in - I know no sex before
a fight because partly Shannon is a like
a big Shannon's a chastity belt he's
like it basically Shannon I suppose of
you or Shannon is your trainer it's like
a mental chastity belt the whole time
because you're like if I [__] anyone
he's gonna punch me yeah well I I don't
I don't think I think that their
relationship is I think Logan is the one
wearing the pants oh yeah I think he
controls how much he wants to train and
how much he well how much he wants to do
and when these data arcade and this is
tough I'm good here yeah laughs yeah
this is good what do you think that
because of where Shannon's career is he
sort of needs long yeah like I think
Shannon cares more about being
irrelevant not not saying that with any
intention but I think he's not cause he
doesn't be relevant before yeah you said
it I didn't say literally so tightly
your video pops like you could get
entire when it's personal so it's cool
and he's getting a bit heated between
you two
no now you're taking it personal if he's
taking it personal that's on him I'm not
aggravate there was a minute Wales in
between these two on stage one [__]
hell I hope it doesn't get was a t-shirt
part yeah there was a moment where he's
like you know when an old man just
contact the joke the way a young man cut
he's getting a little bit I fought you
especially when you're like Leon
the national doge at the end is oh yeah
how regimented is it yeah like right now
like what are your days I owe you today
don't like what I say compared to the
last white like I mean you do you know
you've been said I didn't train as much
yeah the last file I was I was telling
him to train more really yeah compared
to the Jo fight the Jo fight was like
90% then I think the locum part was like
70% really now is that guy like he's a
hundred attempts in yeah like I barely
see it was because the JA fight was so
personal and I think so I hate and it
was the first fight so you know it's the
first one you really wouldn't improve
like okay I can fight I come back right
and then when it comes down to the
second one you're not okay I've proven
like who's this guy and then you get
like a little bit of complacency and
then it changes things well I looked at
the schedule and like like didn't last
year I didn't train as hard as I should
have man like I was just doing too much
other random stuff by filming or just
going to festivals etc but you just felt
like you had it yeah because obviously I
was like ah
Logan's never box before maybe he's
trained for like two months I've been
training for almost a year I've got this
like I don't even really need go hard
and then that's I guess why I was a bit
stumped in the first two rounds yes I
rod he's like he's actually like showing
some boxing skill here and obviously
like my experience came through in the
end
but I think after that I was just like
oh I can't take this lightly
but I have to like go hard now this time
like I know there's going to be a
rematch
that's why the souza happened as I live
let's start training like yeah I believe
believe me so it's a car you were wrong
I honestly believe like if Logan was
ever gonna be you a would have been in
that first yeah that was his upper jaw
what's the logic based on that bro
JJ's complacency mixed with Logan's
intense training made for an even fight
because was one guys chillin other guys
working on okay boom you mean
a balance now he's alerted the guy that
was ahead of him to make steps to run a
him and that's exactly what's gonna
happen
there's there's another side of that ya
know it's a long Ennis is Logan didn't
have as much training then and now he's
gonna have a lot more training and maybe
this is gonna give him an edge in the
next fight we're gonna [__] find out
honestly Conway this is why it's
happening yeah because if we knew who
was gonna win by just guessing you'd
want to watch I feel like whatever
happens we're getting a decisive win in
the next one because yeah there can be
no more like head cards concussion for
everyone yeah but I just think it is
going to be very clear because there's
gonna be there's so much time that
you've had to train and learn boxing one
person is Christian beam forget the
other as you're both athletes like your
bullies have you failed like and I said
that Logan I was like I know you're
strong but JJ has got this [__] freak
stamina though if you can't buy that
yeah and it is just going to come down
to who's the better boxer and who's had
more or less sex he's not less
yeah I'm sure that'll be a factor that
because that was not in Logan podcast
that was what he said he was like I had
sex with was it was it here you had sex
with Chloe I was it Jake had sex two
days before you [__] yeah Jake had sex
two days before you know that's why
you're struggling that's why I reckon he
struggled against edgy and we were like
well we can break it down the videos the
other reasons your struggle the
heavyweight championship of the world
will come idiot [__] no if you get no
you said in his film is that it was
burning an eye for that again it's
pretty impressive
do you remember the moment when someone
that Eddie Hearn steps in and goes right
let's make this professional now because
before everyone was sort of like ice
youtubers having a little fight and then
suddenly Eddie Hearn goes nihilus let's
take it yeah why Eddie's been you know
always wanted to be head gods and I know
Leah
my manager wasn't too keen cos he was
just like like this is a whole new world
it's gonna be a bit more scary Bauhaus I
know let's do it like [__] it like
there's no point like I'm just thinking
why would anyone want to watch me versus
Logan again we've had gods it's just
like the same fight said like everything
I've done you always have to switch up
you always have to change that something
to find a new way a new reason for
people to want to watch something so you
know I'm making a pro fight was the best
the best I guess idea for it remember
when he approached oh the first time
someone said to you um I don't I don't
know when I mean it was just a long
conversation literally after the first
fight but it was just that back and
forth and like it was pretty much our
team like saw most of it what's that
feeling like to have someone like Eddie
her and be like I want I wanna be part
of this I mean I mean it's cool I mean
it's it shows like how far the YouTube
community's come like for the mainstream
to want to get involved like the mace
you got involved the first one like ago
a good amount of the mainstream and now
every once again nice it's lychee Queen
because they just see the views and
they'll come believe never had music the
thing goes on [__] sky subscribers in
a week yes the numbers are ridiculous
and I think you are mentally like I
think you know you are Logan or mentally
well yeah I mean tomato position we are
we you have to be mental I'm like I'm
Mendel I think I've proven my chance
like Ross threw Johnny Sykes
if you're that rich like this is the
thing you and Logan get a lot of [__] of
proper boxing funds and all and I'm like
you don't understand like these guys are
risking all anyway there's no [__]
reason yeah
other than being number one yes yes
that's something really you're gonna be
rich anyway yeah what box are strive to
do is get in a position where you can
make enough money to have your own
whiskey oh yeah
you literally are already there and
you're getting around I don't get it
like I think it's literally like hit the
nail on the head like being number one
it's important because it's bragging
rights it rich its content for years I'm
able to be like I be Logan and I'm able
to make videos on that I Drive mother's
a washer I just guys have know something
new yeah what a job that was did you say
the commentary was good like there is
that phrase that you always talk about
with Mike Tyson wait waking up in is it
silk sheets yeah there comes a point
where you don't train it hard that's
what a lot of box already woke up in
silk sheets though like you already I'm
not I'm not being funny when I say that
like you were already fine we've beaten
the host yes huge but you are already in
silk sheets so we're like I know I know
it's all well and good saying like are
my motivation comes from being number
one but what is it that gives you that
like that actual fire I mean it's just
to like see how far I can go and see
like yeah just how far I can take it
like I started as a FIFA gamer and you
know I started a little kid just being
like Iowa you know it'd be sick to make
money of this and then the opportunity
came and I took in I went hard with it
and then I just kept going and kept
going I was like okay maybe I can make
this a job and then I worked and worked
and worked and then I was like okay like
maybe I can go into the music and see
how far I can go with that and I worked
and work and it's kind of just
constantly seen how far I can go like
that's why I tried the movie as well see
now if I can go with that
and so and so forth for now the boxing
is like the next thing and I'm now like
let's see how far I can take it like I
don't see me gang a world champion Oh
being a world champion like I think that
ridiculous I feel like I missed the boat
but it's one of those ones where you
know you might be Logan pool and you
know I fight a journeyman I find another
journeyman I fight Jake or whoever and
then I keep going and all of a sudden
there might be an opportunity where I do
fight someone for what I mean and it's
kind of like I mean it's ridiculous
Trust is ridiculous but like you never
know it's one of those things where I
never thought I'd be a boxer a pro boxer
five years ago I never thought that
would ever happen and then you know you
just things happen and opportunities
come and you just keep going and then
you just see how far you can take and
right now it's kind of like it's not for
me it's not about money I got money
I got I got plenty of money [__] gym
I've seen this thing just I could just
sit back and just do Simon videos all
day and just because I glanced over
there going why don't you then yeah but
it's just I don't know it's exciting
just to see like where I can take it and
that's why i put in the word that's why
I grind that's why I sweat hard and you
know I think personally for me I think
boxing is like one of the toughest
sports in the world because it's so
mentally draining and physically
draining and it's just constant and you
have to think quickly you have to think
smart it's not just about how who can
fire a punch the fastest or who can
punch the hardest it's about learning
you know where your feet on how where
you are in the ring and wondering or
wise each other like this and that's
this is a mistake he keeps doing okay
let me capitalize on etc that there's so
much to it and I just I'm obsessive and
I love it you know before you get in the
ring when you're
the way that I I don't know what
happened I felt in the last fight you
weren't as calm as you were in the well
I fight you were yeah Armour is there a
thing that you go through like me and T
in that life I hum as you are common to
pressure more than most people I've ever
met like I think it's just practice it's
just like experience like believe it or
not the tour helps so much like me going
on tour helped tremendously like
performing in front of crowds and you
know not worrying about how you know the
interaction or just like them disrupting
my flow it was just me being able to
just go out there perform make have a
sick show and then leave and just be
like yeah I was sick people don't
understand how weird it is like when I
was in front of all those thousands yeah
I don't do that often so we are [__]
what I mean it's you can tell like and I
always say whenever I see people even
with the rose I saw everyone's just
shaking my everyone's just nervous yeah
because it's it's literally a nerve but
like it's kind of like it's experience
the more you do it the easier it gets
the better you get in it and I feel like
that's important because obviously you
can be sick you could be insane behind
you know when it comes to boxing
sparring and all that and then when you
come to the main stage in front of
everyone just [__] yourself and just
instantly be like [__] like that's not
the joy I think a lot and that's what
happened you know who sees well when you
get hit it's a shock you do you go into
shock if you're not used to it and you
take a punch from someone else out there
to hurt you it can send you into shock
yeah then you happen to Joe everything
use of the head gods obviously I've seen
your training without a head gun yeah
but I don't imagine your training where
it was a 10 ounce gloves so the night of
the fight is not going to be the first
time Tennant nor head guard the first
time you're going to feel that that's
the thing he's gonna feel a little
vacuum of
a big right hand mover to know the
intensity no I won't beaten exactly know
you would log and get in yeah football
for you time to take each other's head
off it's gonna be the first like you'll
feel that for us at you well I mean I'm
fine I'm not getting hit that's Michael
and like a plan yeah this is like
obviously you know it's it's a boxing
fight you know and like I know I'm going
to get here maybe at one point but I'm
sure I'm planning on not gang here and
making him suffer through that do you
remember the first time you got hit by
Logan like what your thought was if you
were I did you know that's a good
question I thought it didn't really
affect me he doesn't have that much
power which is crazy yeah which is you
know they're gonna clip a [__] I think
it's his style or how he bridges he
doesn't really put his body into it I
agree
I mean yeah that's one of the things I
think technically from the first fight
he definitely doesn't step in the junk
that's a lot more disarmed love and the
power it's like the reason why he's
doing that is to avoid King hitting just
because it makes his range because he
isn't committing fully yeah I seen that
that's why I think you'll come out with
more intention
well if Shannon Briggs don't even to go
off I would expect he's not gonna be as
like tentative this time you all come
with a bit more aggression when he did
talk you he didn't he didn't follow it
up last time that was a lot of
experience from him he's kept out one
page yeah I love Jay Jay back in the
fight yeah I wouldn't doubt what would
happen if you push that pace on him from
the get-go Howard yeah and I see your
cardio was undisputed yeah I was just
ready like a constant I'd say boxing
experts they critique this fight I was
thinking like JJ's called yo was
actually pro boxer level like yeah
you're doing understand that he's they
even fight we yeah yet spar in yesterday
and his lost friend was his strong is
running for the most part
I'm saying like his conditioning is
always up to scratch yeah getting the
man right and then and I think it's even
more crazy because like I'm heavier
right now yeah I was 83 84 84 the last
fight what do you know I'm not massively
I must admit I know good in terms of
like um you two look the same you know
the Seidman right this is this is
growing and growing growing it's up in
millions of subscribers what is the goal
for YouTube like it's a bridge is it
gonna be building this into a huge broad
assignment while is there an endgame cuz
right now it just seems like keep
killing it but why is it by the way
Simonson yeah well naturally its above
his fight so we're gonna talk yeah I
don't think there is an Ingo I think for
JJ he's obviously got is like boxing
music and everything I think everyone
else YouTube is the main focus so I
don't think I think it is literally to
see how far we can take it so the same
thing you talked about it like you guys
never been like here's the road map
here's the plan not really cuz obviously
all the American side they they all just
look for investment phase and that yeah
yeah where is why not he's spoken about
it we all would be open to it but it's
not that's not our goal cuz Seidman it's
a cool name like I look at it as a
branding this could be huge like with
with the right business mind behind it
not that you guys don't have it but you
know we're just young guys or ever
attracted like I'm sure there's people
out there who could take that and go
those mix muscles yeah I mean we would
be open that is the thing of I mean if
things keep coming up like the boxing
for example so we've been working pretty
much every day for the last two weeks to
get ahead just wise period yeah your
merch yes what kind of light what kind
of numbers we talk in tracks everyday
interests yeah yeah Logan Logan
delivered some numbers on the lust and I
know your numbers will be strong as I
said pressure when you guys livestream
head-to-head the press conference you're
getting five times his life I feel like
you'd lie though I don't know because
when they're on the Forbes list him and
Jake are [__] like 20 million a year
what did he say he said him at the mid
35 million in a single year when they
when they launched maverick to be fair
we know when I mean unfortunately you're
splitting it seven ways but yeah
maverick or was huge in that yeah I
don't think he's lying about her but I
just thought [__] me the Seidman are
doing bit saying that I wouldn't no one
here I'm asking for numbers like that
but you know what I mean there's no I
actually don't know any exact amount
right
I'd say we're making above seven figures
mm-hmm yeah yeah well I I would expect
so yeah yeah I thought but like I don't
know it's kind of just gradually growing
which i think is probably better rather
than a massive spike and then but a lot
of consistent yeah I think we've kind of
got like a good brand where it's just
constant growing were growing with the
audience somewhere well cuz Logan had
his blow up on YouTube four years ago
roughly something like that was really
blew up around a certain video yeah but
in terms of merch yeah it was like four
years ago something whereas we only
started last year yeah I'm a long way in
a short space yeah I was just wondering
because I don't know you guys could have
your own trainers and [__] clothing
label like I know you've got Marriott
emerge but this could be like that's why
I feel like that's maybe where we're
looking in the future yeah to do big
opportunity to take big opportunities
like that and to do collabs with big you
know like sponsors or big industries etc
is there a reason you've never present
company excepted [__] the guys often
gone on your own because I make a lot
more money on your own but you've always
stayed so loyal because I just morph
honest I just enjoy it more not me but
like a lot of people wouldn't have done
that and I respect it I think I think
it's just how I've been brought up like
you know when I started the whole me
being case I blah blah blah like it was
with just me but I mean even then I was
still like you helping my program
helping goose on now you know helping
Simon but forget the open good John and
I mean dad she's got [__] nine
million subscribers like what have you
done you happy with the time to watch
these videos I'm like yeah they related
what the relationship like them at the
moment are you talking at all or is it
just like let's just leave it at that I
mean with this we're just I'm not
digging me I don't know it's just it's
it's it's complicated because it's
family it's just common yet especially
how public it was yeah it's never like
the best thing and it just yeah it's one
as ones where over time maybe they'll
get better but right now yeah we're just
gone I'm grateful that stopped yeah yeah
saying those things on stage but like
are you just but I'm you know you
couldn't hear half of it but you know no
dice I heard he was talking about dizzy
you would the LA presently are you
pulling out like legit because I went
through it during Christmas and all
those months after etc like at that
point how she's numb to it like like
I've literally been through the worst of
it and it been so public and everything
just made it even ten times worse but
you know you can't get any worse than
the worst so at that point I just you
know just felt calm about how is just
eyes cool public public what's hard to
do stuff in public when you're youtuber
like you've just got in public with your
relationship not long ago like that's
not really a thing I would have a
thought yeah while ago but like I don't
think maybe at Brian's only just found
out because she post no photos with you
but you pose with her maybe Brian didn't
know that but you know I mean like I
don't know I didn't ever expect that
from you but you like really like yeah
there's some girlfriend we do videos
together alright okay and it was a it's
dodgy when you bring a girl into the
[__] frame because you don't know if
this is gonna work out and if it doesn't
work out what if she [__] says stuff
about you after the fact like the Simon
have been very careful generally about
that
was this sort of something you
considered before you made yeah we were
dating for about six months beforehand
and it was like a yeah that was a very
it was a hard decision to do one for me
I didn't feel like I have the enemies
like he has no no you're very like
you're like like so you'd be good but I
don't know I guess you had to weigh her
up you had to weigh her up before like
the loyalty factor because some people
just want to use you just get that
[__] Instagram me in the eye when you
say no some girls just want to build an
Instagram and go right I'll see you
later smash you know I mean we see
youtubers become victim of this all the
time yeah so you must have known this is
a good one but I'm good yeah I still
hope so yes that talent the other way
though I guess and like it's not just
like is yeah yeah [__] suit look and
go with it like there is natural talent
do you know what I mean one of the best
songs on the album weird for you having
your best mate and your girlfriend
collaborating on a song yeah a little
bit of trust issues though you guys are
in this 200 dollars singing like
together
Randolph is like we're gonna stay over
and sleep in the same bed that's fine
Randolph conceited I be added lots of
gotta stick together mean on the same
brand off the same yeah I've got off
silence the whole [__] no I don't
think so
this is where me and him held each other
at the other de jure the roast he
dropped the line that everyone just was
like it was like a funeral and I was
like very ashamed
trying to help lords over sword I love
those situations that's when everyone's
like really uncomfortable she's think
why I think we like making true news is
like I don't actually really care that
much about what's happening on YouTube
I'm actually just like some of the
shit's gonna be really funny but we're
gonna say about this but then I actually
that was what was actually really
unusual for us is because we did true we
started tree news around the time when
all the like family stuff logo and stuff
all that stuff was going on it came
almost uncomfortable for us covering
every week didn't it while we were like
[__] this is actually serious and sad
most Christmas here mud it from the
districts where it was like yeah yeah
and then it just got yeah and then
there's the whole Christmas thing and
everyone was like I think it's weird
when people are looking in almost taking
like pleasure in your pain yeah buying
is like it's intriguing people are
intrigued by that because they're like
think [__] That's not me
[__] 6jj like why don't you just leave
the other guys he's helped us in terms
of YouTube obviously I think we've
helped him keep it fun same as me
yeah I think you would have probably
stopped buying that not stopped YouTube
in total yeah well you wouldn't be doing
as much no not at all because like I've
been doing for so long yeah and to find
like new ways to excite me it takes it
just takes a lot tell us about it do you
ever get a bit sick of those like digs
though where it's like you're only here
cuz know my first like 3 years on
YouTube was just that right ok yeah I'm
used to it by now
yeah and I feel like I've done it long
enough that it hasn't happened dead
she's kind of taking that attention yeah
yeah a lot but like I don't care you
know I'm like I see I'm just okay I use
your name to clickbait me
is that are you only bought million
because of jr. is that okay well
millions of millions it's gone
that's true not many people actually get
a million views anyway yes my name is
yeah because you can put like we know
this you can put Seidman and ksi and the
tags Oh ever and always do every week
yeah but the points you don't always get
the million views there's so many Pro
boxes that can't just get a million
views yeah pretty much every other yeah
really
besides aging yeah an AJ will get but
only when something goes wrong exactly
like he's for it but before that you
wouldn't have been getting millions of
views is it frustrating though because
you are also a talented boxer and a
tanana run time no I don't forsake me
because I know I have the time to prove
what I need to in in the ring you know I
mean sigh right now I'm doing what a lot
of fighters don't do which is build the
brand outside and like I know I can
fight I'm always improving so when I get
back in the ring it just I'll just prove
everyone wrong I was really surprised
because we obviously got to see you guys
like preparing a little bit before the
last fight as to how I guess like what a
sweet relationship you two have got and
I don't mean that in like an undermining
sense he's younger but yeah he's your
big heard him talk about your chef and
stuff like that oh no no but he's just
like yeah you need to eat better yeah
yeah yeah yeah she I heard was she
bringing you like no she's here right
now
like I really thought it was very
there's not many men who have
relationships where it's like this
someone who's actually taking care of
you and is actually being like attentive
and nice and he came to you guys with
doctors on money which is oh [__] to an
avail and a new and Logan are like we
can't do this ourselves and make that
kind of money why I mean I mean I
Logan's team did [__] all they just
didn't know what was going like cuz he
left it on them welcome to sour their
own event and they were just like like
Jeff it's useless man I have you seen
the guy he literally looks like he
doesn't know he's doing 24/7 he's just
this sure little guy
but like yeah so we were just trying to
get a sword let them do that thing
nothing happened that's why then the
fight just didn't happen when it was men
happen so we're like alright let's try
and sort out through Eddie and you know
we had Eddie we also had a showcase Wow
to show time we're also talking to also
we're talking to ESPN maybe I'm them or
another so one is pretty much one of the
big ones I will just you know like going
back and forth back and forth and yeah
Eddie you just made the most sense yeah
literally the most sense and those are
up two dollars and yeah yeah well like
another Bell oh yeah I hope so because
I'm not taking that Bell now you own I
thought that was too big - so its own
yeah yeah hopefully they make it like
not in green like something again a
customer's bow yeah something sick
[__] diamond play a button right in
the movie yeah oh my god are we nuts
what you going for a ring we're wise cuz
that the both fights now you've probably
been the better dressed of the two was
even much on the last one - I thought
Logan's like you know that black one was
sick as well I thought that was good I
think but
to make black look bad yes yeah yeah
well I've got this sick loads of
Pavarotti
black oh he's just a fat man in a black
suit were like I'm alone instead he's
dead sorry you can't run the dead for
the Union Chuck look men I like that no
III was out to represent the you yeah
but uh this next one I'm going for
something that just looks unique like
something that will glow in the dark
oh yeah so it's like it's gonna be all
dark and there's just gonna see me just
like shine off like all black and red
and it's just gonna be lit not to have a
mask it's gonna look [__] hang mask
last time is pretty me I never forget
we're ringside
everything is on commentating just went
the best YouTube song even Logan wanted
to come out that's crazy how does it
feel when you're on ITV and Piers Morgan
is just like sucking you off for like
five minutes
sucking me off like his Morgan's a bit
of a weird you're the king of the
internet so he does everything he can to
be like oh my man he's like he's black
and he's young I better get with him
he's quite competitive what's the smell
like I know I don't know man money you
know I smell good no bang I'm just
curious because it's interesting because
you're seeing youtubers out of context
is really weird like I'm used to seeing
you sitting your bedroom bed in the
background like headphones on you're
watching something like I'm used to
seeing that so see on TV always feels a
little bit weird
it's even weirder when you're sitting in
a living room without your dad and your
dad's like have you met that one and
it's like yes yes but then they're
asking all these weird questions to you
I how much money do you make all those
things like they I guess on TV they they
kind of just they're still trying to
understand it all yes it's all quite new
to them new to them right so us it's
just we've been doing this was so long
to a point where I would just I guess
sick and tired of it and say the same
thing but uh yeah like I remember back
in the day when they would ask that
question how much money do you make like
you do in FIFA videos how much money do
you make blah blah blah you're the fool
it's how much money do you make excetera
so I like to see that it's still the
same question after all these years kind
of shows how far TVs gone given away
people always ask that question
people always ask that question once are
you another box has told you or they
saying [__] like that then they think
I'm rich because of YouTube yeah yeah
yeah yeah use I know you're rich you
never need to fire them I do yeah fine I
see it's no one's business you really
just gotta do what you gotta do man hide
your money make your money cool
I do find it kind of weird because it is
like a lot of other boxes say a lot of
crazy [__] and like other fighters say
loads of crazy she's sweet Aroldis buns
and this Ferrari oh okay compeletely has
no broken girl again lucky laughs that
is Ferraris the best listen you have to
become undisputed know each other
because that is mad but I've ended the
less very mean it kind of like cuz I was
I know like now the arrow spends less is
Crawford fight yeah it's gonna be pushed
back even more to see it but now it's
all good no I'm glad he's fine have you
have you do you enjoy watching boxing
yeah
love it like before like I used to know
get it if that makes sense the animal
when i watch the Mayweather vs. Pacquiao
buy everyone was going on about this
just to fly off the Centurion yeah huge
and like the point where I actually you
know managed to get into the arena to
watch it
Wow and I was watching outside this is
the most boring fire though she won my
fight no knockouts like I'm like what's
going on like none of this makes sense
it's just hogging like they're just like
tapping each other like I don't get it
obviously now I fully understand how
like the levels are like and how it's
like just insane Mayweather is if you
just shows like how defensive how smiley
is defensively and to be able to just
slow down Pacquiao Pacquiao is always
just were quite were quick worker and to
manage manage stood like bring him right
down to I guess may workman's level and
make me whether fight his fight like
it's just crazy like and and now you're
gonna train in his gym with his family
for a fight earlier how [__] you talk
about this is what you've thought in
your life I feel like I should come up
with a red book remember this only only
other person who remembers it yeah now
when you're watching cuz that was sort
of gonna ask you that do you feel like
you've educated JJ because he's talking
out it looking at someone else's plan
I'm picking it that's not something that
just happens overnight is it that's the
advantage for the fight is that yeah his
IQ is high and he's understanding the
sport mm-hmm like I can do maybe four
defensive moves with out someone for him
punches at me didn't ask him what
punches were coming at me imagine what
punches were coming and he could name
all of them these are the things that
are gonna change make the difference in
the fight because he's now seeing things
clearer like before is that JJ jab why I
just do it cuz we ain't got time to
learn why now yeah okay distance okay
okay that one's gonna take a bit air
away like he's starting to understand
all the uses of the weapons so you know
summers is gonna be fun it's gonna be
fun even something as simple as okay
you move to your right yeah I just like
oh why you moving to the right to avoid
this power hand or yes like it gets it
now yeah and I mean there's so much how
many times have you watched that last
fight so many times so many times it's
sorry for the comet and me I think I
wish there were six times you know all
right man I was you like my own account
yes sir Lawrence calls finish him off
yeah annoys me like all the time
watching it because I'm just there like
I'm so [__]
legit like I I was like so [__] compared
to where I am now like I just know so
much more I know what I should have done
I should have just there's so much I
mean I don't want to say here like
everything I need like all his strengths
and weaknesses accelerate but like
there's so much I should have done and
I'm going to do and like I just felt
like but then I was just complacent and
I just felt like I knew way more than I
thought I did and I thought was I we've
seen but all getting angry yeah yeah
yeah what was that like cuz you know you
got a great relationship in all of us
and your mentors or even at you that's
the thing like that's again our advice
you know that Shannon Briggs is a former
world heavyweight champion
so obviously is gonna have knowledge but
you don't bond with Logan on how a
bondage aging so certain things I can
just look at JJ and go just do this
though yeah yeah and in all of a sudden
it clicks whereas like I don't think
they have that relationship it takes
time to build that I've been the last
war so that yeah yeah boy it's just you
guys even do something that's it and
then I was just like oh [__] because
obviously we got JJ listen to what Leon
saying but in certain things I can just
go gg because it's been that long
this is what I think all we're like a
Champions League football I couldn't
necessarily
managed an amateur football team like
because you've come from that background
you might be more suited to this level
of boxing than Shannon would because
he's so far removed from me way away so
we're we're here the level up we're out
here so maybe that is an advantage in
itself yeah because I I'm not okay I'm
removed for me but I'm not that far away
to remember what I was being taught you
know not so long ago exactly so you know
that that's where the youth comes in to
interpolate because five years ago I
would have still been boxing still been
learning Louis five years ago I don't
know what Simon you know during the
first fight with Logan
obviously I remember the first round
thinking holy [__] Logan looks confident
he's doing really well
the the confidence that JJ came in with
was like he's gonna walk through this
and then all of a sudden you realize odd
Logan see a stay what was that like for
you watching him fight is the worst like
the well a fight I thought he was losing
the whole time well it doesn't I'm like
is that yes done it's done yeah and then
I'm still watching it back and I might
yeah well it didn't throw a punch the
Lausanne fight I'm dizzy after two
rounds I'm looking around on the side
it's done I was boxing about Sam's days
that oh good luck man and you can see
he's just that he said about you I think
we were yeah yeah Simon is the most
nervous of all of it
we need we need one of the lads to just
cuddle you fro though it's gonna be okay
oh yeah it's horrible because I get
nervous obviously when I do other stuff
like the charity matches and stuff yeah
I think it's actually worse watching
someone else cuz I have no control over
that
mm-hmm and you're pretty good under
pressure like you squat from the halfway
line just goes that game I flew up
before that really there in the changing
room because I was breaking it Wow kind
of strange because like everyone's there
to see you do well everyone's there to
be like most people in the arena are
like he's so beautiful like no one is
there going I hope he [__] dies like
no it is different but I get it because
they're different mentally on you very
yeah yeah like the Wella fight hmm you
were nervous I we had breakfast at the
house everything quiet you might see in
the yeah and as soon as he got to the
crowd he was there like oh okay
let's go yeah yeah whereas I would have
been the other way around the morning of
it I'd have been like sure it'll be all
right yeah see the crowd yeah it it's a
bit of a drug this crowd thing isn't it
I must admit cause even when I went out
there and felt them cheering for me just
say your name I'm not to always take it
back but like this was the first time
since everything that gone on for you
where you didn't know necessarily how
the public saw you or about you so when
someone goes true Jordy they could have
all been like you know what could like
but instead there was probably like the
loudest cheer
those glasses [__] they were brave
ladies as well tweek I said the logs
before I had half a bottle of whiskey I
was like should I throw my classes
although be fun and use I will throw
them like that so we times we will I was
like now throw them differently and
brines there in space in the middle of
the dress room just going like this
[__] trip yeah this crowd are miles
away the press yeah there's I'm really
[__] throw this we nailed it so
generally speaking I want a little
prediction of what Rowan do you think
this is gonna end in round five round
five yeah
so I changed my mind you know but I'm
not gonna say none I change my mind on
that you two have different predict we
assume that he's gonna come out quite
strong I've lost and explosive because
he's dead like it's ten ounce no head
gods [__] it let's go like I'm probably
gonna catch JJ and that say it's gonna
be easy that's why I keep saying round
one run this you know like decapitation
etc so he's gonna go ham for maybe round
one round two and then if that doesn't
work then he's [__] and then he's just
gonna gas out the muscle is gonna weigh
him down tremendously and he's just
gonna struggle to move and I guess he's
gonna maybe write off round three and
four and maybe try and hope to come back
in round five but I think by then I
would have done so much damage that it'd
be concurrent and then just gonna end
him so that's why I'm saying I'm fine
going back to Cho what's your
relationship like with Josh all of this
cuz it was so bad at one point because
of because of the little things you did
in the run-up and some of the
yeah somebody took it so you let that go
is there always gonna be a little
something there I don't like I only care
the sky I've reached out and asked him
to comment it for the fight oh snap
and he rang me and he was like yeah I've
told them to get you and they're like
yeah but EMS are a bit of a problem for
having you comment having can comment it
and I'm like you do know you've got a
log and Paul [__] fighting like no
offense but like of all the things
that's happened he's atop them yeah yeah
and I'm somewhere yeah no one was harmed
in the making of my second message yes
pinkeye but no but if you didn't want
your commenting you could have that and
yeah yeah I was like I was fine with it
I like I don't really care too much like
what he does I'm like it's really a
point where it's like I did my thing and
now you know it's his life it's my life
and I'll just move on well I respect
that the yeah you're allowing him to
still no I wouldn't you know yeah I
wouldn't hold a grudge like I wouldn't
yeah I don't normally hold a grudge if I
do like yeah I didn't it takes a while
like who's the losses that a massive
graduate who's on time yeah good I had
the longest grudge and then you know I
went to our society
I forgot why I hate them it's just like
you think how successful you are makes
it easier just let [__] go um no it's
such a position of happiness and power
well I mean yeah you know I think it
probably plays the part I know when my
life's going good I can forgive people
for all sorts yeah when I'm struggling
I'm like a [__] hope you die yeah I
imagined Joe probably wants me to get be
like if like somewhere deep inside him
he kind of wants me I wouldn't blame a
minute so you can see so I can see how
he feels
oh how he felt when I know that
obviously this in your mind isn't even a
possibility in terms of like
you know you've done the work and you
feel very confident but if you were to
lose career-wise yeah do you feel that
affects you moving forward pride wise
and ego wise you'll find me quite a bit
but if anything it'll just make me even
more of a beast I think like either way
I'm going to be like at least like for
me it's I've always told myself it's not
about winning it so it's always about
you know like maybe if you get beat how
like how far you can go I mean over
what's the phrase like I feel like
you're saying about the journey itself
no no no no it's you you know you can
get beat but like it's how you come back
it's how you know how strong you come
back and like for me it's always being
short making sure I can come back
stronger
so you mean leaving in 2017 just because
I was just like no in a good place I was
just you know deployment right after our
podcast yeah yeah I was just like I just
wasn't feeling right and no I remember
but then you know I came back stronger
than ever like and then if anything yeah
I just became even more popular even
more relevant even more etc like I just
like that's how I how I am always feel
like I'm always gonna come back stronger
like yeah okay I'll lose to Logan then
I'd be like [__] it I'm gonna be a pro
fire I'm gonna beat other profiles I'm
gonna be other people and then be like I
I'd be all these people [__] it like
Logan really want a rematch yeah like
that's like my mentor has already
decided like if you didn't win you'd go
again oh yeah I feel like that's how I
am because I just I feel I just same and
I feel like we might be looking at a
trilogy here what it depends on his fans
I think that's it that's it for like
like duck thought is so far back in my
head it's like like that's mean it's
interesting for us to know
like there isn't a day where I'm after a
session I'm there like last year where I
was like I should feel right you know
like after a session miss no that must
be disappointing as a trainer when
you're like no offense to Dida Dida home
yeah I see fights every single training
well for your PT now Dida is obviously
not the same as we're talk about the
mayweather gym here we're not talking
about the same are we and you know even
Leon like like I said I loved either so
much like he's taking me so far like
where I was at the beginning and where
did it took me like I will never forget
that because he has done so much for me
and he's allowed me to be in the
position I am today I needed to take it
to the next level and that's why I got
Leon and Leon like he is ruthless he
doesn't give a [__] he's there like if I
was that in it yeah beau I'm dead I'm
done Leon say no you wait we working we
don't keep going if I'm dead like I
can't bar I can't do any more pull-ups
he's like shut the [__] up rotational
doing it as well it was like he was like
a little pixie like pulling these
teachers he is a machine enjoys like
watching people important and people
know he enjoys like putting himself
through pain himself like he enjoys it
yeah so I I needed him to take me to
next level because I myself like I just
work hard anyway so I needed Leon to
push me to that next level to turn me
into a psycho to a killer and then
without just help me with the boxing
technique and boxing boxing IQ and just
you know just making me just the
complete boxer and making sure when I
come into this next fight I
just levels above anything anyone ever
thought and people are gonna be like
[__] why not bet money and low get your
finger I like his conditioning is
already amazing yeah we've got Leona's
smashing it from the shrimping
conditions inside but in Morgan Vegas to
train with Larry wait he's also on
camera
Luis Ortiz who's preparing to fight
Deontay Wilder so he's gonna be on the
track with world champions and you
nobody's preparing as well so he's gonna
be training alongside watch other free
weeks solid he's gonna see them and
telling he little tips that they you
know they use it's like ass I'll throw
it in and say listen I'll do this movie
yeah so we're in a camp where we're
surrounded by the top guys in the sport
that's gonna make a difference your
cardio is gonna like it's gonna be
stupid it's not in front of me I did say
like not like early rounds people are
gonna expect Logan to be the stronger
but late a delay other fight cause like
yeah yeah that's safe for me unless
there's a freak punch there's only one
one other layer of this fight goes on
yeah all right it's if you can survive
that early obviously on so and I that's
gonna be my explain what am i yeah I'm
gonna be cool because you know it's got
all that monsters got all that master
hour
[__] it let's go let's see what happens
and then he's gonna realize I'm a
[__] machine like you can't [__]
move me like I was I say with the loss I
was tentative I was you know I was just
avoiding [__] now I'm not afraid to get
here now I'll stare you in the face and
be like you punched me and that did [__]
all now I'm going to punish you for that
and Logan's gonna see that and it's
gonna just get a show of him so I was
saying to Jason like everyone has a
breaking point and you once you find it
that's it
some people it takes a bit longer than
others jaws breaking point was very low
Logan's has proven to be higher but in
round six we nearly found it those are
seven we would hit so it's just finding
the breaking point in this fight and
then crushing it and that's what we aim
to do you make a compelling case
it's amazing because every interview
that we do its wings one way and
afterwards you're like wow well not on
the table I think he's just doing all of
that [__] to cover that he's nervous and
I think he hates I'm not showing
anything I think he he enjoyed that last
night because he was able to go okay
look he's doing missed I can let's work
on this all he's doing this now it's got
nothing and now obviously like he's not
showing [__] himself but I think he's
that's nervous energy and to hide that
he's doing all this flamboyant crazy
[__] just I get yet to hide it in the
press conference I felt like Logan was
being I think in terms of confidence he
came across as more confident yeah when
you got to the faceoff yeah you started
talking yes he didn't he was silent and
I was like ah
JJ's talking lots of [__] he's not
saying anything
Wow so when I was telling him like you
know your fault your your main coach is
Shannon Briggs you are you serious like
I'm telling him like I've got a mad camp
in Vegas I'm Richie training like with
champions I'm going to I'm training like
a killer and you're not ready for this
I'm literally a completely different
boxer and I was telling him all in this
and he was just looking at me like
trying to just not take it in but I
could tell he was taking it in and I
felt like he was there like oh [__] like
this is different like compared to the
last time last time I was so funny and
you know it was like a comedy show
disarmed serious some when I'm serious
[__] you know she gets done yeah that's
what I mean like yeah we fight weak you
see everyone's true emotions yeah cuz
you normally have the press conference
the public workout that's when you
really start to see everyone's behavior
who's truly been confident from the
beginning hmm and who was acting because
when you know in three days time the guy
you've been dissing he in steps on them
skills in his best shape possible that
is when you you really got was the well
at moment for me when I thought that you
well I'd not face the fish yeah oh yeah
I'm saying but before that when you what
you enjoy and what bite you would have
all and everyone have you seen this I
don't need to see and then we know that
there you go yeah that's pretty rapid
there lots really it's a [__] great
to hear what you're saying and I know
when they get an absolute classic fight
this is gonna be really sick and like I
think it's amazing what youtubers have
done I think because I've been there
from the beginning you know with like a
hunch and seananners and even people
before that blame true for etc and to
see us as a community go from there to
where is now I think it's insane I'm
just so happy
mm-hmm I've got one other questions
before okay because I'm looking like
what YouTube is and you remember you see
like all TV and the guys later on in
there like one day you're gonna be on
some [__] show and you're 50 years
old and you're gonna be talking about me
and Logan throwing punches and Logan's
gonna be all this what you're probably
going to be sat next to each other laugh
another genuinely this could go he's
seen a cop will be there with our kids
going I remember when I almost
commentated that would have been so good
to LA know when you look back at this
door how do you think you're kind of you
young JJ [__] been taking on the world
and punching someone in the face in
front of millions of people I don't know
I you know I I don't know I guess I'll
just be proud I just be proud that you
know I had a I had a mentality where I
never gave up
you know I always had people telling me
you can't do this you can't do that and
you know I always felt like an outcast
in my life and to finally just to order
to tell people you know [__] you I don't
care what you think
I'm going to do my own thing and now
people see me as the inspiration and the
leader essentially I guess I think
that's I think that's pretty cool and
yeah I just yeah it makes me happy I
think it also makes me happy that I'm
able to bring my team with me I think
you know doing this by myself would be
quite lonely but to have my team around
me like I think it's just the best thing
and yeah the whole of the UK is proud of
humans all right good luck good luck the
darling human that's going out there
it's gonna be a great shock always you
in Vegas is dangerous isn't it yeah yeah
don't forget to like this video
subscribe all that [__] thanks to all
the lads for coming on appreciate it
we'll see as Leah